we're doing at the city are we
hey guys oh yeah hi today where are we
headed to hula
oh we're headed to a gifting suite at
anime impulse okay so I know nothing of
enemies nothing right so that's why I'm
so happy that cool dad is here with me
so she's gonna be my enemy translators
for today so I don't know what Rilakkuma
is it's a video what is it
it's a bear it's just don't leave this
really cute bear and it's just a
character it's just a character it's not
Kyogre but it's just like I don't even
know a pedo bear is Oh today I will
learn about anime you get an education
and then it for those of you that don't
know anything about enemy you will learn
to with me thanks to who yeah
you're in your element girls
handle right here yeah just tell me what
these like dope-ass cotton candy that's
actually doing shape and I'm so excited
we're gonna take it off so you guys new
shape cool kind of shape see you guys
soon
Oh can I get a hard
oh yeah every go we know what's up
tonight
make the shape
cute is so cute
god
disappeared
baby
because it going me about the heat
my life seems like
Oh
I came is the best
oh my god
totally matches its entire like play
leader rainbow from head to toe and I
rhyme
like I was wearing I love this
it like frames of your boobies really
nicely I like it very good job life
supporting you rocket mow your rocket
what'd you get what is this oh these are
popping fish what they have like stuff
on the inside I'll just eat it
yummy
Oh
Oh
cutie-pie
to
oh my gosh so cute I loved her costume
what is this she's a big fan you're so
sweet oh dude I'm really really loving
this
so apparently AT&T sponsored this whole
area very subtle
good job agency you are cute not being
so cute julia become excited here that's
so cute that means so cute right about
this grooming I know
this is adorable I will actually like
this in my room right now I know girl I
know you don't have to live on a child
no we are Jessica and Cassandra and just
kidding me
I know
there we go ah [ __ ]
okay that was the mission okay so this
is Dragonball Z okay I've heard of to
that okay good because the 9 mm so this
is go through and discuss Vegeta and
then they're in the Super Saiyan form oh
I thought this was the same person no
they're different I don't know anything
look at the hair tip they look the same
they're both blonde bangs he doesn't
happen I don't know it's just like the
same dude with the different get up
that's it get with the program out of
ignorance okay they're from the same
planet oh that means nothing to me nice
I'm just gonna king thanks for trying to
teach me cool what about all this other
stuff that one that one I'm not too
familiar with oh that one I'm not too
familiar yeah okay so we're just the
most famous one Dragon Ball Z yeah cool
educational I like it where is the exit
so apparently we're trying to exit or
where we came in
and they said no we can't let you go out
this way
to the front with Duman where we came
from oh yes we go all the way around
they're making us even more late for
reading okay okay don't be like the
whole that's like passing here
yeah been able to have okay I don't know
to a boiling point yeah they ran out and
then they they told us that they
wouldn't have it anymore I'm like
addicted to that tea I would I would buy
like three of them a day it's really
unhealthy human now as she just
important me
it's my exit
so after asking somebody who works here
they told us they exit the same thing
that we just exited yeah exit dammit I'm
thirsty and I would like to point out
the fact that Julia is such a good
friend that she's carrying my back for
me because I was cutting into my
shoulder I love her so much
man this is a mere string just believe
no you got it going catching me china
runny you're just walking we are 30
minutes late everyone's already here and
the meeting started with notice this way
I don't know I'm still getting used to
this new office space
that is not offense yeah we can start
filming all right yeah the echo the
sound quality is amazing
Oh Eddie Mitchell oh you're sick I can
hear you Liana make that magic really
refund
okay I'll get sick with you so this is
our new studio space that is completed
and we can now start filming
just kidding it's an inside joke so
pretty much we kind of fell behind in
the whole construction schedule thingy I
don't know that's why we had this
emergency meeting because we need to
talk about what happened so this is the
office admin we clearly can't move in
yet cute cute cute cute cute cute cute
cute cute cute cute yeah cute cute cute
cute cute
awesome well thanks for following me
today on my day of this day alright guys
we'll see you next time pizza pie